the point of no return is going to be at
the exact midpoint it's the point at
which something happens that makes the
hero fully commit to the goal because in
stage 3 in the progress stage the hero
is still vacillating he's got one foot
in and one foot out so Cathy knows he's
supposed to do this but he always leaves
open the option of leaving of giving
over to another lawyer of not doing
anything to make ways but then because
Dalloway confronts him and says and this
is where another inner conflict moment
is she's arguing with him and and he she
says where daddy so I expect where
daddy's expectations so great that
you're not willing to actually defend
these guys and he says spare me the
psychobabble and they have a big
argument and then Weinberg his other
reflection his friend says you want to
use an argument that didn't work at
Nuremberg and and Kaffee jumps in and
says these guys aren't Nazis these are
too poor you know Marine cadet or Breen
private or corporals who did something
you know that they were probably under
orders to do and then galloway turn
statement says be careful you're making
an argument meaning you're starting to
be a lawyer and again she's functioning
as a reflection who's saying don't back
into your identity this is your essence
follow that and so because of that the
next day when he goes in to ask for a
different attorney and he says instead
of doing that he enters a plea of not
guilty because his defendants were not
willing to take the plea he got from the
Kevin Bacon character because they said
that wouldn't be honorable so now he's
putting everything on the line because
if he pleads not guilty he doesn't think
he can win and if he tries to win by
accusing another officer of committing a
crime he could be court-martialed for
doing that so now we're moved into stage
4 what I call complications in higher
stakes and this is when the outside
world starts closing in meaning this is
when new facts come to light he didn't
know
means Jessup knows that he's after him
so they're going to try and manipulate
more stuff to go against him it means
some the soldier Markinson shows up but
says I'm not willing to testify so he
comes into the picture because he's the
one who knows the truth about what
happened and the only one who might be
willing to tell them what really went on
there but he says I won't testify so
things are getting tougher and tougher
that's the complications the higher
stakes meaning if Cathy loses now he
loses everything there's more to lose by
failure and more to gain by success and
now the obstacles get bigger and bigger
and bigger
you